we're thrilled to be joined here on uh
peacock nbc sports on peacock
uh is uh is a delightful human uh my
kids love it when he shows up on a mass
singer just absolutely loves us
well they love kids love joel mchale
adults love joel mchale
everybody loves joel mchale and sona
soon he he's
he's joining the pantheon i will use the
word pantheon whoa
whoa pantheon of game show hosts
he guest hosted this show look at that
huge ass
chip he's holding in his hand every game
needs a wild card
card sharks coming up on sunday night on
abc our buddy joel mchale how are you
joel
i'm still uh each of those chips weighs
about
uh 45 pounds so a great workout well you
you you do flies with that right
i know and you in your workout right
absolutely with the amount of hph
running through my veins
joel the quiet part that shouldn't be
said out loud like that just
don't do that i'm sorry uh what is it
major league baseball ten years ago no i
just know i think
no i i think once upon a time gene
rayburn uh got sat down because he
talked about juicing
um and i don't want your game show um
to be a problem okay just don't want it
i do love watching the old match game
on the game show network because it is
the most wonderful jailbreak watching
betty white
richard dawson fanny flash
yeah they're all drunk and or slightly
buzzed and it's
just it's it's great it's just
i was just like that uh it just and it's
always like 1974.
their outfits all look like they're in a
musical now yeah it's just
incredible brett summers and charles
nelson riley smoking a pipe on the top
of the top row and
it's funny you could see them every now
and then on tv and i was sitting there
watching with my nine-year-old the other
day joel
watching an old match game and and the
clue was
so-and-so just got fired you know john
just got fired and he's so embarrassed
because he was replaced by a blank
and we're sitting there going robot or
something and the
female contestant said woman and all six
of the uh people said woman and they
matched it and my son was so confused
and i'm like
different time different different
time different times oh there are there
are i mean some of the stuff they allow
on the game show network because some of
the answers
are pretty rough
you can't believe they would this was on
television back in the day but it was i
would
i'm i'm literally racking my brain right
now trying to think of an example that
is not going to
end up with big trouble
well i gave you one i mean seriously my
son and i he was so confused and i just
shook my head i'm like just different
time
but uh wait i cannot wait for card
sharks do you have a
a long microphone as well like gene
rayburn
or well as you know uh gene rayburn died
when he impaled himself
through his nose and came out the back
of his skull so uh
no alex baldwin uh on the match game
yeah a new one
he has the uh solid gold one so i uh i
just
i have a i like to call it a pedestrian
or typical mic
okay i wouldn't try to uh take that yes
i did not see the debut
uh of card sharks this past week but i
will be uh
locked in because i i love you and i
just love the show it's
it's such a it's such a simple game to
play um
it's very simple but with each i mean i
i hate to i mean i'm well you know me
i'm the first person to be sarcastic
about everything that moves
and uh when these people win they can
win like 600 grand
which is uh in the spectrum of game show
winning
these days that i think millionaires the
only thing that comes close
uh and by the way speaking of big
winnings you and i were on the pyramid
together yes we were
yes that was and i guys who's ever
listening
rich eisen was terrifying at how quick
he was
and the only reason why you didn't get
to the hundred grand is because the
very nice woman who was super quick she
said the clue out loud
she read it she read it yes and i'll
tell you what joel
um and i don't know if this speaks uh
about me more than anything else if it's
a window into my soul
uh that pissed me off because she ruined
it for me
she you know that's not the usual sort
of
general sense you're supposed to have in
a game show but it just means
the network had a very hard a very hard
time hiding your rage
because uh you turned bright red
and you the you grip the side you know
the
things that you ripped your chair apart
frankly out from underneath you
and uh strahan had to restrain you it
did it
stray had to restrain me joel mchale
here on the rich eisen show host of
abc's card sharks that you can uh
check out at 10 p.m on abc's on sunday
nights right here on the rich eisen show
all right let's get into it um let's get
into it
i'm not worried at all next week next
sunday about how they're being you know
going up against the world series game i
think we should be fine
no no no and but you'll at least be out
of uh
the woods of uh your seahawks will be
playing earlier in the day against the
arizona cardinals
so we just talked for one sec about that
finish against
minnesota oh my lord go for it
oh no i was just like i would just would
anyone ever doubts russell's ability to
do anything
i just want you to check that out that
last two minutes it might
my wife and i lost our mind jumping up
and down and screaming that our dog we
had to put our dogs in a separate room
well i mean if you think about it um the
seahawks play
football games like pete carroll
chooses gum right i mean like it's it's
not
normal it's just a it's a chump it's
just a constant chomp it's a jittery
chomp that um that just leaves you on
edge um the entire time it's like pete
carroll's personality and id almost
that's on display with these games but
when it all comes down to it you got
number three and now you got number 14.
i think that's the best quarterback wide
receiver combination in the nfl
with russell and dk metcalf what a dream
it must be for you to be sitting back
and watching those two guys
work oh it is just believe me and dk
mecca
is 22 years old uh so
he's got he's got a lot he's got a lot
of years left thank god i'm sure we're
gonna have to pay him about 900 million
dollars but what happens yeah no it's
believe me because seattle we spent the
70s and 80s a lot of the 90s with people
just making fun of every sports team and
unless ken griffey jr was on it and uh
you know we got to the finals and uh
oh we sold our basketball team and we
got to the finals with uh
peyton and and sean kemp but uh we were
you know we ran into a freight train
called michael jordan so
uh anyway when we won in 14 and then you
know we lost in 15 and we continued to
be competitive
every year i think we only missed the
playoffs once uh
and that it's just it just makes me so
happy
it gives me i literally i think it's the
greatest distraction from the pandemic
he's been they've been amazing i mean
russ is definitely the mvp
the crazy thing is that it and then this
has been mentioned over and over and
over again he's never received a vote
for mvp before
which is mind-boggling but he's going to
it's mind-boggling it's not right if we
have to
now that you know seattle is super
prosperous it used to be that nobody
cared about it now it's kind of harder
to brag about you know to be like
well you know seattle just kept up there
in the corner and you're like yeah with
microsoft and amazon yeah okay whatever
so
yeah it's great so i'm just i'm thrilled
you should be
so joel uh as a seahawk fan if you think
that
let's let's let's match uh your two
loves right now with the seahawks and
card sharks oh okay if you if you
had to risk it right now saying that the
seahawks should go
higher with their level of play or
freeze it
based on making the super bowl what
would you do right now joel
run the risk or freeze it gonna say
higher
because everyone underestimates number
three
and then they're always i guess
disappointed
or surprised because he always steps up
and he will always find a way and i know
that drives teams out of their minds and
makes
us so happy so higher higher baby higher
all right pull the card
chris pull the card no inside there's a
patriot fan pulling the card it's a bad
prank
it's terrible that good it's terrible
it's just no good well
uh what are the chances that a patriots
fan you know cheated
i can't hear you hold on let me take the
rings out of my ears oh boy
there we go everybody i don't yeah
i know just go pump up one of those
rings with uh oh excuse me deflate of
the
ring oh boy this is great i'm enjoying
this back and forth immensely
there's so much tom brady during that
time well
everyone's going to be fine they're all
millionaires everyone's happy
oh my gosh my kids cannot get enough of
seeing you on the mass singer
joel they just can't uh well i
look singing blurred lines that i
thought was gonna
you know if i had screwed that up badly
i mean more than i did it would have
been career suicide but right god i got
through
uh i have so much fun on that because uh
ken needs ken jong needs all the help he
can get yes
yes he does he's he's a terrible doctor
and um and so he's a terrible joke so i
it's just great that i can go on there
and help him
so again you're you're a dad and uh as
well
um so at what point because my kids
can't get enough of ken jong either
um they're 12 and they're nine at what
point
uh and what heads up do i give them when
they
see the hangover for the first time um
well you could show them the airline
version
uh it's the in-flight version which
uh they did a version where he had some
underwear on oh really
okay yeah all right i don't know i don't
know if that exists
uh but yes you could just say
you know this is the real world and that
is a man's penis
is that your fatherly advice joel i mean
um yeah
that is i think you you steer into the
storm there like
a navy you don't go around it you steer
right into it and
uh you just yeah what are you gonna show
them the hangover
i don't know it's gonna i think it's
gonna have to be a few years
you know we just showed him the karate
kid like that's where we're at right now
you know like that actually just we just
showed that maybe
during while you're watching the
hangover when the scene comes up
you just jump in front of the screen and
go isn't bradley cooper a revelation
well the problem is with that is uh the
projection system
uh might actually project ken jong onto
me
at that point and that might be even
more jarring than anything else that's
creating more
that's what we call an unintended
consequence you know what i'm saying
maybe you should work up slowly with
some of my tens other movies like all
about steve
and vampires suck and uh you know you
work up to it maybe they'll
develop a resistance well we'll
start with card sharks how does that
sound we'll just start with that i like
that
setting with yards fantastic
uh congrats on that um let's uh let's
keep talking down the line
um contract on card sharks and we'll be
watching sunday night 10 p.m
on abc if the world series is on
do you have to watch the sporting event
because of the business you're in
well yeah there is also something called
um sunday night football as well but
look uh i'm a big game show fan
and i'm a big joel mchale fan so you
know there's
there's enough room for everybody
there's enough room for it long live
rich eisen
and may he live a thousand years for all
the nice things
that he says and uh um i i
i feel like we should return to the
pyramid and
um oh please i knew that when i won
that over you because not because of
what anything you did because of that
mistake you made i knew
uh it gutted me it really it gutted me
joel there's no other way to put it
it just gutted me but um there's still
there's still another day i would do
that in a heartbeat
i really would but in the meantime enjoy
being part of that lineup yourself
it'll be a lot of fun okay i'll see you
with the combine
i'm i'm really excited to watch guys um
just slowly pace around the track
i'm really excited joel mchale everybody
there's joel mchale right here on the
rich island show
very popular joel mchale at joel mchale
on twitter and instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here